5-ї річниці анексії Криму на порядку денному в офіційному Берліні - немає.
Німецькі газети не виносять репортажі про це на перші шпальти.
Німецькі ЗМІ зазвичай на своїх картах відзначають Крим штриховою лінією.
Та у німецьких політиків сумнівів немає - півострів був та залишається частиною України.
Анексія Криму не відповідає міжнародному праву, вона його порушує.
РФ разом із США та Великобританією дали Україні гарантії в межах Будапештського меморандуму.
Відповідно до цього міжнародного договору,
Україна відмовилася від атомної зброї в обмін на гарантії недоторканості своїх кордонів.
За словами депутата, анексія українського Криму Москвою
має довготривалі наслідки для світової політики.
Хто не хоче дотримуватися міжнародних договорів,
а Будапештський меморандум лише один з прикладів, -
той робить замах на всю систему безпеки,
яка базується на двосторонніх та багатосторонніх міжнародних договорах.
Ця багатосторонність відіграє велику роль у системі безпеки і так повинно залишатися у майбутньому.
З депутатом Бундестагу погоджується і провідний експерт з питань Росії
Німецького товариства зовнішньої політики.
Це було б занадто небезпечним прецедентом для інших конфліктів, до прикладу на Балканах.
А ще, звісно, для всього західного устрою,
який базується на державному суверенітеті і непорушності державних кордонів.
Це не просто неприйнятно, це небезпечно для інших конфліктів.
З такою ж заявою виступила напередодні і верховна представниця ЄС з питань зовнішньої політики.
Федеріка Могеріні каже - захоплення Криму є "прямим викликом міжнародній безпеці"
і "має серйозні наслідки для міжнародного правопорядку".
Євросоюз зокрема відзначає збільшення порушень прав людини у Криму
і підтримує територіальну цілісність України.
Утім тема Криму вже не привертає такої уваги, як кілька років тому.
Теми України та Криму не лідирують у переліку пріоритетів німецької політики,
можна навіть сказати про "деукраїнізацію",
відсутність бажання пов'язувати всі теми з Україною, бо вони надто великі.
Проте я б не сказав, що Україна неважлива.
Штефан Майстер підкреслив, що Німеччина відіграє центральну роль
у переговорах щодо врегулювання ситуації на Донбасі,
а німецька влада і надалі підтримуватиме санкції проти Росії.